- [Wendy] It's like my world is washed out,
and I see fewer shades of
color than most people do.
- [Maureen] So normal
people see a million colors
I may see as many as 100,000,000.
(bell music)
- [Wendy] My name is
Wendy; I'm a producer at CNN,
and I'm colorblind.
- [Maureen] My name is Maureen
Seaberg; I'm a tetrachromat;
and I'm an author.
Tetrachromacy is the presence
of a fourth cone class
in your retina.
If I keep naming my invisible colors
maybe I'll have my own
Crayola box one day (laughs).
- [Wendy] When I was in Kindergarten
my teacher called my parents
because I was coloring
the leaves of my trees
and the trunks of my trees the same color.
Because I couldn't
really see the difference
between green and brown.
- [Maureen] The only time
it was ever overwhelming
is a paint contractor came to my house
and brought no fewer than 32
samples before I was satisfied
that it was a true beige.
- [Wendy] When I pick
out clothes, that's hard,
I have been known to buy the outfit
that the mannequin is wearing
because I know that that goes together.
- [Maureen] You don't want to
go clothing shopping with me
because the sales people
tell me, but it matches
and I can only look at
them sympathetically
and keep looking.
- [Wendy] I never think like,
oh, if I weren't colorblind
it would be so much easier
to get dressed in the morning.
It's just, it's kind of part of me.
- [Maureen] I guess I'm a
unicorn or something. (laughs)